so brian stelter this is this potato
clown guy that's on cnn he hosts a show
called reliable
sources and this is their sunday news
recap show and i i kid you not you know
i've always been sort of a student of
the media of tv and politics i always
loved all this stuff even really it
started when i was about 10 years old i
sort of remember when i was sort of into
this stuff and my dad would be watching
these things and i would be watching
them and it used to be reliable sources
used to be hosted by a guy by the name
of howard kurtz who now is on fox news
but it was basically like they would
talk about like what's going on in the
media what are our blind spots can we do
something better can we really hold
power to account howard kurtz i thought
did a pretty nice job doing it and he do
he does a similar show if i'm not
mistaken on on fox these days but anyway
brian stelter took over from him i think
it's probably about 10 years ago or so
something like that and stelter's just
awful if you want to just see like the
type of person that's just part of the
machine and just wants to like suck up
to all of the worst people constantly
and when he thought things were horrible
under trump now the same things happen
under biden but you know we don't talk
about them anymore or we
somehow obfuscate them or whatever it
might be well first just listen to this
question you're going to get the answer
from pasaki but listen to the question
that stelter asks pasaki here's clip one
what does the press get wrong
when covering biden's agenda when you
watch the news when you read the news
what do you think we get wrong
well look i think some of our muscles
have atrophied a little bit over the
last few years and there isn't
a lot of memory or recent memory or long
longer memory on how long it takes to
get legislation forward or how messy the
process of negotiating and the process
of getting legislation across the finish
line can be so we know we understand
everybody's always looking for a
deadline a timeline things like that but
at the end of the day our focus is on
getting these bills across the finish
line doing it in a bipartisan way if we
can and we certainly recognize that that
can be messy along the process so i
don't know if that's the press getting
it wrong
i'll leave you to the critique of that
brian but i think sometimes we forget uh
how strange the last four years were and
when we returned to a place where
democracy is working where we're talking
with democrats and republicans where
we're trying to get bills and
legislation passed yes when we return to
a place when democracy is working when
we're all blowing each other constantly
and nobody is saying anything remotely
close to true i mean forget her answer
she's just she's just the worst but his
question what does the press get wrong
why would you ask the press secretary
that that's the person you're supposed
to be challenging that's the person who
is the face of the white house every day
out there with the press that's the
person you should be asking all the most
incisive questions that's the most the
person you should be asking all the most
pressing questions that you should be
pushing and prodding to get to something
closer to truth and he said what does
the press get wrong when covering the
biden agenda that is the worst sort of
oh i mean they literally stelter is
basically a puppy who wants a cookie
that's all he is he's a little
a fat little puppy who you know some
puppies you know he got into the cookie
jar too much but he's just down there
like please can i have another cookie
can i have another cookie that's
i want a cookie all right if you didn't
think that was bad enough then stelter
asks pasaki because she's known to speak
truth he asks her about truth
journalists who watch what you do what's
your advice for them about
trying to stay here close to the truth
in this world of lies
well i think what i try to do is stay
grounded to the facts and what i mean by
that the details and what we can help
provide publicly to clarify context to
make it more understandable to the press
to the public
and it sometimes it's not more
complicated than that
oh lord give me the strength it's only
monday forget again forget her answer
she just says words like it's just word
word word noun adjective adverb okay
she's just saying nothing but that's her
job to say nothing um but asking the
press secretary
about truth
you stelter you're one of the prime
purveyors of lies you push the russia
hoax the covington kids hoax the brett
kavanaugh hoax we can go on and on about
the lies that you push every week then
there was this other thing last week
speaking of stelter and his network cnn
where jake tapper said that he won't
have liars on his show anymore and he
was talking about a couple republicans
uh who were defending trump you know
over election stuff a few months ago
that he's not going to have these liars
on his show anymore and then uh what's
her name stefanik what's what's her
first name elise stefanik i believe uh
who is a congresswoman out of new york i
think maybe staten island if i'm not
mistaken she posted screenshots it's
actually spectacular of tapper's people
asking
her to come on the show at the same time
while he's saying he's not going to talk
to these people they're all
liars they're liars and they're it's as
if they're like laundering the lies with
each other so you get stelter talking to
pasaki it's his job to lie it's her job
to lie let's all launder the lies
together and we'll all lie all the time
and as i quote all the time now this
alternating quote
we know that they know they're lying we
know they're lying they know that we
know they're lying and they continue to
lie well it's just going to keep going
people it is just bananas